you're never too young to start a
business if you believe you're too young
then you're going to be too young and
it's going to hold you back as long as
you believe that you're too young you're
never going to have success hi I'm Evan
Carmichael and I believe that hungry
entrepreneur's deserve help in same age
and the question from one of my youtube
viewers capitalize ur 44 and we've been
going back and forth on a video with
comments on and on and on and the
summarized capitalized 44 is 15 years
old wants to get started in the computer
business making mice for gamers because
he's a gamer and he has ideas on how to
make the mouse better and he was
wondering is he too young to be doing
this at 15 pissing you're not too young
you're not to anything if you believe
you're too young to old to whatever then
you are and it's not going to work but
as long as you believe you can do it you
can my first real successful business
was when I was 19 years old as a
software company so it wasn't that much
older than where you are now the key
thing here for you is you got to learn a
little bit about the industry okay I
can't help give you advice on how to
build a mouse you got to learn about the
business and as you get into it see if
this is still something you want to do
maybe it's taken an internship at a
company that makes mice or doing
interview is talking to people who do it
to get their feedback on it right you
want to have a plan you want to research
and have a plan improve your knowledge
but you can do it if you take time every
day dedicate it to this and I would
spend your time not your money go out
and research it create a prototype the
lease on paper and start talking to
people and see if we think is a good
idea i see if we can get some orders for
it you can solve everything you can find
a manufacturer you can find out how to
make it all of the logistical problems
that come with making a mouse you can do
age has nothing to do with it it's your
belief in your conviction if you believe
you can do it you can do it you've got
to get started I try to dedicate time
every day the research in this idea and
as you get into it you may find this
isn't what I want to do you know it's
really hard there's not a lot of money
in it whatever whatever problems come up
it may be too much for you hey that's
fine
start something else it's got to be
around something that you're passionate
about and it may still be something
related to gaming even if it's not the
mouse but you'll never know until you
actually start trying and you'll get the
information by doing the research and it
doesn't have to be something that sits
in your plate until you're how old 18 19
20 25 when you think you're old enough
to run a business you can start if
you're young you're hustling you got
ideas you're willing to do the work it
doesn't matter how old you are you just
got to start just gotta start good luck
for those are you watching you like the
video please give it a thumbs up below I
also want to hear from you if you have a
comment on this video or question for
your own business please leave it in the
comment section below I always read
those I love seemed to come in so thank
you guys so much and I'll see you on the
next episode